hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a South Korean action series
called weak hero class 1. spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
Park ji hoon is a high school student
with an extraordinary Talent he can
solve complex mathematical equations in
his mind with the help of which he
performs daily activities he runs plays
and even fights using math but being a
genius comes at a cost jihoon has zero
social life he spends his entire day
studying and barely talks to anyone it
is rumored that jihoon has never smiled
in his life because of this he has no
friends in fact all of his classmates
call him a creep but jihoon doesn't care
the only thing he takes seriously is his
exams one day he wins a prestigious
award for his excellence in studies this
makes all the students jealous in
particular sugiom the class bully so he
decides to go after jihoon he smacks the
genius with a slipper and pretends that
it was an accident however jihoon
doesn't retaliate he simply says don't
do that again tsugiom takes that as a
threat and prepares to beat him up but
just then some senior boys barge inside
the class they are looking for a certain
Hyun wuk who apparently teased one of
their girl then from the last bench a
seemingly nonchalant boy gets up from
his sleep he introduces himself as Hyun
wuk and tries talking his way out of the
situation however the seniors are having
none of it and they soon attack him the
entire class looks on with fear in their
eyes and it appears as if Hyun wook is
going to get his ass handed to him but
shockingly despite being outnumbered he
dishes out a brutal punishment on his
seniors he doesn't even break a sweat
during the entire fight all the students
are left in awe of Hyun wook's martial
arts skills but jihoon can't wait for it
to end so that he can continue studying
the next day sugiyam and his bully gang
again tries to intimidate jihoon they
hide his books and pretend as if they
didn't do it later a frustrated jihoon
confronts them in the storeroom and asks
them to stop unfortunately it turns out
to be a bad idea as the bullies quickly
Corner him and beat him up punch that
into your calculator jihoon jihoon is
left humiliated in front of the entire
class but he is not bothered one bit the
bullies notice this and become
frustrated no matter how much they try
to break him stand strong but just then
tsugiom comes up with an idea he knows
that jihoon only cares about his grades
So He suggests they ruin his exams at
night the bullies go to a nightclub and
buy some narcotics from a local dealer
sugiyama also buys a packet of Fentanyl
patches an illegal substance that causes
people to hallucinate and puke if
applied to the neck the following day a
new student arrives in class he is
beyond siak a shy and nerdy guy who
happens to be the son of a wealthy
Minister the bully sugiyam immediately
identifies him as his next Target so he
does a little research and finds out
that biomsiak actually transferred
schools because he was excessively
bullied in the last one tsugyam uses
this information in blackmails biomsiak
to do something evil since the exams are
going to start in an hour he wants the
nerd to stick the fentanyl patch on
jihoon's neck biomsiak has no choice but
to agree so as soon as the exam starts
he slaps jihoon from the back and
cleverly sticks on the narcotic patch
the latter is angry that he was
Disturbed but beyond uncyclized that he
was just swatting away a fly soon jihoon
starts feeling dizzy prompting him to
rush to the bathroom there he pukes for
hours and by the time he returns the
exam is already over jihoon loses it
when he realizes that he is going to
fail for the first time in his life he
grabs a pen and heads towards the
bullies to punish them along the way
everything turns into slow motion and
jihoon uses his extraordinary brain to
calculate his moves he then picks up a
thick book and smacks tsugiom right
across the face the nearby bully tries
to react but jihoon stabs his hand with
his pen then he covers sugiom's face
with a curtain and repeatedly bashes his
head with the book the punishment is so
brutal that all the students can only
watch in fear fortunately before jihoon
kills the boy the martial arts expert of
the class hyung-wook stops him the scene
then cuts to the hospital where sugiyam
is being treated for the injuries his
mother is by his side and she believes
that he was bullied soon jihoon arrives
with the school's principle and issues
an apology however soogi mom wants him
expelled believing that he is a
notorious boy who can harm other
students hearing this jihoon brings out
the narcotic patch that her son had
stuck on his neck the principal is
shocked to learn that one of her
students is dealing with illegal
substances hence instead of punishing
jihoon she berates sugiyam the next day
when jihoon enters the class all the
students treat him with respect even the
bullies are terrified of him the nerd
Beyond sock tries to apologize but
jihoon ignores him and walks away in the
meantime sugiyam is visited by his
gangster cousin siak day in the hospital
humiliated by the recent developments
sugiyam wants to take revenge hence he
pays his cousin a hefty amount to punish
jihoon a few days later tsugiom finally
recovers and sets his plan in motion he
along with the gangsters wait for jihoon
at the entrance of this school soon the
math genius arrives and siak day starts
off the proceedings by slapping him
across the face then they escort him
away to a quieter place to beat him up
beyonceok notices all of this and he
immediately heads to the one person who
can fight the gangsters Hyun wook the
latter is sleeping and wants nothing to
do with others Affairs but when
beyonceok promises to pay him 500 he
agrees the two then hop into his scooter
and start looking for the classmate
elsewhere jihoon is getting beat up by
sugiyama and the gangsters using his
mathematical skills he tries to put up a
fight but to no avail tsugiom repeatedly
kicks him in the head but fortunately
before any serious damage is done Hyun
wuk comes flying with a karate kick he
starts tussling with shock day while the
others gang up on jihoon even the nerd
biomsiak chips in to help his friends
eventually the good guys Prevail leaving
tsugiom and his cousin humiliated in
order to celebrate their Victory Hyun
wuk takes the boys to the restaurant
where he works part-time they have a
lovely meal and enjoy their time
together jihoon who is a hardcore
introvert is having dinner with other
boys for the first time in his life
elsewhere ciac day is summoned by his
boss Gil Sue who is angry that he got
beat up by some kids gilsu promises to
take revenge but it first he punishes
siakday to the point that he breaks his
arm in the next scene we see jihoon
buying some stuff from a department
store at the same time one of siach
day's colleagues is seen shoplifting she
picks up lipstick bites the upper part
and hides it inside her back what what
is she a reverse kangaroo when a woman
notices her she immediately runs to
jihoon and pretends to be his friend the
latter doesn't know how to react so he
simply escorts her out but since it is
raining and the girl doesn't have an
umbrella he now has to drop her off at
home along the way they enter a
restaurant and have lunch the girl
finally introduces herself as young Yi
an orphan who is living with shock day
and other friends since she has no
relatives or money yongi started working
for the notorious gangster Gil Sue she
then asks jihoon to tell her about
himself but of course he won't speak
hence she departs the place but not
before saving her number in his phone
the following day tsugiom finally
rejoins school after the series of
embarrassments he suffered at the hands
of ji Hoon he goes straight to the three
boys and reveals that he is in trouble
because of the narcotics found on him he
is being sent to juvenile detention and
the only way to avoid it is if jihoon
and biomsiak testify that he is innocent
to show that he is not lying sugiyam
even drops to his knees and starts
crying seeing this the boys decide to
pee on his head I mean help him sugiyam
then escorts them to a parking lot where
gilsu and his gang members are waiting
young he is also present and as she
watches on gilsu approaches the boys and
threatens them to provide fifteen
thousand dollars compensation for
beating up his men they have three days
to do so or else their families will pay
for it before leaving gilsu makes a
small cut on Hyun wuk's face to give
them a demo of what will happen if they
don't pay up from that day onwards the
boys are followed wherever they go the
gangsters make sure that they don't
escape the city out of the three
beyonciak is the most anxious because he
fears his father will find out about it
so on the deadline day he sneaks into
his dad's room and steals an expensive
watch on the other hand jihoon decides
to call the cops but first he wants to
gather information on Gil Sue's illegal
activities so he contacts young Yi and
meets her at a restaurant as they talk
jihoon gets to know that young he hates
her boss as much as he does she is tired
of his ruthlessness towards teenagers
like her hence to take him down Yankee
reveals about all of his illicit
activities it turns out that gilsu has
an illegal betting app where people
always win a few hundred dollars at
first however once they become
interested and bet more money they lose
that's not illegal that's just how
gambling Works in this way hundreds of
students go into debt Gil C tracks every
single one of them and provides them
with money when they can't pay him back
he forces them to join his gang and do
illegal stuff the next morning the three
friends gather in class and decide their
plan biomsiak has the fifteen thousand
with him but the other two assert that
it is not required then jihoon reveals
everything he knows about the notorious
gangster and his activities his idea is
to somehow reach gilsu's place call the
police from there and catch him
red-handed shortly after the three exit
the class and see the gangsters waiting
for them since it's a Dangerous Mission
Hyun wuk decides to go alone he
approaches gilsu and straight away
mentions the gambling app according to
Hyun wuk the cheating scheme in the app
is flawed and can be beaten he explains
the entire process leaving Gil Sue in
shock at last he proposes that they have
a meeting at gil Sue's place so that
they can work on the app together and
improve it the gangster boss immediately
agrees and asks Hyun wuk to get into his
car after they leave a scared beyond
siak also departs in a cab fearing that
their friend might get into trouble
meanwhile Hyun wuk arrives at the
gangster's Hideout and secretly texts
the location to his friends using his
smart watch unfortunately his intentions
are soon discovered so the gangsters
beat him to a pulp shortly after a
scared biomsiak arrives at the location
and tries to offer the cash but he too
is apprehended Gil Sue and his gangsters
then pack all the essentials and flee
the place right before jihoon arrives
with the cops in the next scene an
enraged gilsu calls siok day and berates
him for allowing the boys to trick them
he then Reveals His location and asks
asks him to join him immediately siakday
knows that he's going to get punished so
he decides to go alone but young he
insists on going with him reluctantly he
agrees after a while jihoon calls Yang
Yi and inquires if she knows where gilsu
has taken as friends the latter texts
him her live location asking him to
bring the cops ASAP meanwhile gilsu and
his gangsters have gathered at an
abandoned amusement park they have tied
up the two boys and are preparing to
execute them for treachery just then
siak day shows up with young Yi enraged
that he brought the girl along Gil Sue
starts battering him with a metal bar
but this time surprisingly ciac day
Fights Back tired of all the abuse and
Punishment endured over the years he has
decided to take a stand the other
gangsters also don't intervene and with
this siakday and Gil Sue engage in a
professional fight it goes back and
forth for a while but in the end using
his experience Gil Sue gains the upper
hand after subduing siak day he goes
after young Yi and begins choking her
but suddenly police sirens are heard in
the background around the terrified
gangsters quickly run away and as soon
as they do jihoon shows up he
immediately goes to his friends and
unties them however as they prepare to
leave Gil Sue and his gangsters return
with jihoon's mobile phone it turns out
that the police sirens were fake they
were simply an audio clip played on the
phone as a result another fight ensues
Hyun wuk despite being injured takes out
several guys while jihoon also subdues a
few with his intelligence I have some
long division boys but right then the
cops finally show up for real now all
the bad guys are arrested except for
young Yi who manages to run away
following this we are taken to the
police station where jihoon and
bianchiak have been called to give their
statements once they are done
beyonceok's personal lawyer meets them
and provides some good news they will be
completely forgotten from the case as if
they were never involved in it this
makes jihoon somewhat relieved as now he
can finally focus on his studies again
in the final scene he along with young
Yi visits Hyun wuk at the hospital the
latter has a few broken bones but yet he
is still in the mood to joke seeing him
so happy and cheerful jihoon Smiles For
The First Time in years shocking
everyone in the room I didn't know he
had teeth to see what happens next watch
the second part in series recapped